Paris Hilton's boyfriend just got her
name tattooed on his body and it's huge
oh my god never left this came home and
surprised me with Paris tattooed Allah
and Disney Fong I love you
[Music]
actor chris Zylka surprised the heiress
with some ink a tad of her name in
disney font on his forearm I'm so
excited
the former reality star took to
Instagram Thursday night to showcase the
romantic gesture writing such a lucky
girl
my love surprised me he said because I'm
his most magical place on earth and he
finally found his fairytale princess
hashtag boyfriend goals Paris confirmed
their relationship status in February on
Instagram and a few weeks earlier the 36
year olds couldn't help but gush over
her mystery man to ET his amazing
beautiful sweet loyal my best friend
then in May the summer rain singer and
the leftover star told et that their
love is the real deal filming you wake
up with a smiling you fall asleep with a
smile being best friends and finally
finding someone that
and trust and know that I want to spend
the rest of my life with the best
feeling in the world the actor even has
Paris's family's seal of approval my mom
loves him she definitely approved it's
just so happy she already says he's part
of the family
[Music]